bonjour monsieur je vous remercie d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
pharma jamali fash choisi une date
symbolique pour lancer une attaque
contre la politique nucléaire américaine
les 75 ans d'hiroshima quel est son
objectif selon vous je pense qu'on est
dans l'animation diplomatique avant
notamment la réunion de l'onu qui se
passera dans quelques jours sur la
demande américaine de maintenir un
embargo sur les armes conventionnelles à
l'égard de l'iran donc c'est une manière
de détourner un petit peu l'attention de
remettre un petit peu d'autre part la
tension avec les américains le vrai
problème effectivement c'est le nom et
le retrait des américains de cet accord
sur le désarmement nucléaire de l'iran
que les rend finalement n'accepte pas et
surtout continue à d'après l'onu a
augmenté ses capacités au moins d'accès
à l'armé nucléaire à terme
alors justement comment la situation at
elle évolué dans la région depuis le
retrait américain des traités sur le
nucléaire iranien
nous sommes le traité le nucléaire
iranien pour moi représente plutôt un
prétexte à mais un prétexte au sens de
la paix au niveau du moyen-orient
n'oublions pas que les états unis sont
très proches d'israël qui est une
pression israélienne pour empêcher
l'iran d'acquérir une arme nucléaire qui
pourrait menacer l'état d'israël il faut
jamais l'oublier un deuxième temps aussi
c'est que cette arme nucléaire commun a
été exprimée comme une menace contre
israël par l'état iranien depuis de
nombreuses années même si aujourd'hui
l'iran dit qu'elle ne veut pas armes
nucléaires de fait c'est une menace qui
a été prononcée pour réduire qu'israël
ensemble donc les américains sont avec
leurs alliés et veulent peut-être aussi
indirectement éviter à terme une frappe
potentiel d'israël sur l'iran donc
d'entraîner une guerre dans le
moyen-orient qui serait fortement deux
majeurs et enfin nous
non pas le monde arabe avec l'arabie
saoudite en particulier qui a toujours
dit si jamais l'iran à l'armé nucléaire
nous arabie saoudite nous auront aussi
leur nucléaire une menace pour jaouad
salif tall et la place réelle d'israël
aujourd'hui dans la hiérarchie mondiale
elle est considérée comme un état
nucléaire
du point de vue militaire sans qu'elle
n'ait jamais dit publiquement
voilà c'est un nom dit tout le monde
c'est entre guillemets que l'israël
détient l'armé nucléaire et que
effectivement cette arme nucléaire est
destiné à protéger israël contre toute
agression c'est le principe même de la
dissuasion
maintenant la question est de savoir est
ce que c'est une arme diplomatique ou
militaire
c'est à dire une arme de dissuasion ou
dans pour on pourrait supposer quand
même qu'avec des politiques raisonnables
des hommes politiques raisonnables ce
nous cela ne reste qu'une arme de
dissuasion des agressions verbales et
des menaces qui sont souvent dénoncé des
deux côtés que ça soit les américains ou
les iraniens est ce que la menace d'un
conflit nucléaire est réelle aujourd'hui
au moyen-orient selon vous
personnellement je n'y crois pas
tellement ce serait dommageable pour
tout le monde ça serait du perdant
perdant
on a réussi à éviter une guerre
nucléaire depuis depuis très longtemps
depuis 1945
on vient de commémorer effectivement la
première bombe nucléaire sur le japon se
rappeler les dommages sont tellement
importants dans une zone où finalement
l'énergie fossile reste une priorité
y compris pour nous non je pense qu'on
ira vers une guerre s'il devait y en
avoir une plutôt conventionnel l'arme
nucléaire personne je n'y crois pas
maintenant nul n'est à l'abri d'un
irresponsable ou d'un jusqu'au boutiste
voilà je ne le sens pas aujourd'hui même
l'iran dans son discours sait
parfaitement que la monuc les airs n'est
pas crédible en tant qu homme en tant
que tel maintenant en tant qu
souveraineté comme expression de la
souveraineté iranienne
la possession d'armes nucléaires ferait
d'elle une
grandes puissances en tant que tel et je
pense que c'est ça le problème c'est que
ça représente une arme de politique ou
dirons nous on a le nucléaire donc en
tant que tel nous devons être écoutés et
nous pouvons donner notre avis sur un
centre de sujets merci beaucoup françois
chauve ancien d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
général de brigade et expert en
géostratégie